dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr karo jonai feher
if we write the laws of fluid motion
into a computer program
we can create beautiful water
simulations like the one you see here
however with all the progress in
computer graphics research we can not
only simulate the water volume itself
but there are also efficient techniques
to add foam
spray and bubbles to this simulation
the even crazier thing is that this
paper from eight years ago
can do all three in one go and is
remarkably simple for what it does
just look at this heavenly footage all
simulated
on a computer by using blender a piece
of free
and open source software and the flip
fluids plugin
but all this has been possible for quite
a while now so
what happened in the eight years since
this paper has been published
how has this been improved well it's
good to have bubbles in our simulation
however
in real life bubbles have their
individual densities
and can coalesce at a moment's notice
this technique is able to simulate these
events
and you will see that it offers much
much more
now let's marvel at three different
phenomena in this simulation
first the bubbles here are less dense
than the water
and hence start to rise then look at the
interaction with the air
now after this the bubbles that got
denser than the water
start sinking again and all this can be
done
on your computer today what a beautiful
simulation
and now hold on to your papers because
this method
also adds simulating air pressure which
opens up the possibility for an
interaction to happen
at a distance look first we start
pushing the piston here
the layer of air starts to push the
fluid which weighs
on the next air pocket and so on
such a beautiful phenomenon and let's
not miss the best part
when we pull the piston back the
emerging negative flux
starts drawing the liquid back
one more time simulating all this
efficiently
is quite a technical marvel when reading
through the paper
i was very surprised to see that it is
able to incorporate
this air compression without simulating
the air gaps themselves
a simulation without simulation if you
will
let's simulate pouring water through the
neck of the water cooler with a standard
already existing technique for some
reason
it doesn't look right does it so
what's missing here we see a vast
downward flow of liquid
therefore there also has to be a vast
upward flow of
air at the same time but i don't see any
of that here
let's see how the new simulation method
handles this
we start the downflow and yes
huge air bubbles are coming up creating
this beautiful
glogging effect i think i now have a
good
guess as to what scientists are
discussing over the water cooler
in professor christopher berry's
research group
so how long do we have to wait to get
these results
you see the quality of the outputs is
nearly the same as the reference
simulation
however it takes less than half the
amount of time to produce it
admittedly these simulations still take
a few hours to complete
but it is absolutely amazing that this
beautiful complex phenomena can be
simulated
in a reasonable amount of time and you
know the drill two more papers down the
line
and it will be improved significantly
but we don't necessarily need a bubbly
simulation to enjoy the advantages of
this method
in this scene we see a detailed splash
where the one
on the right here was simulated with the
new method and it also matches the
reference solution
and it was more than three times faster
if you have a look at the paper in the
video description you will see
how it simplifies the simulation by
finding a way to identify regions
of the simulation domain where not a lot
is happening
and course on the simulation there these
are the green regions that you see here
and the paper refers to them as affine
regions
as you see the progress in computer
graphics and fluid simulation research
is absolutely stunning and these amazing
papers just keep coming out
year after year what a time to be alive
this episode has been supported by
weights and biases
in this post they show you how to use
their system to train
a neural network architecture called
efficientnet
the whole thing is beautifully explained
there so make sure to click the link in
the video description
weights and biases provides tools to
track your experiments
in your deep learning projects their
system is designed to save you a ton of
time
and money and it is actively used in
projects at prestigious labs
such as open ai toyota research github
and more and the best part is that if
you have an open source
academic or personal project you can use
their tools for free
it really is as good as it gets make
sure to visit them through wnb.com
papers or click the link in the video
description
to start tracking your experiments in 5
minutes
our thanks to weights and biases for
their long-standing support
and for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching
and for your generous support and i'll
see you next time